- Hey, everyone, this is Jeremy
Schifeling at Khan Academy.
Thanks so much for joining
our session on Best Practices
for using Khan Academy with ELA.
To that end, we are very
lucky to have Madelyn,
one of our superstar
ambassadors on the line today
to talk about that very topic.
How she uses Khan Academy's ELA
content in her own classroom
and how you can use it
in our new remote learning environment.
As a quick refresher, if
you're new to these webinars,
feel free to ask questions at any time
using the questions feature.
After Madelyn lays out
the key points she wants
to share with you about using Khan Academy
in your classroom, she'll
take your questions live.
So share and view the questions
format and here we go.
So Madelyn, welcome, thank you so much
for joining us today.
- Absolutely, thank you so much.
- We're super excited to have you here.
And just to give folks a sense
of where you're coming from,
tell us about your own
journey as an educator.
- Absolutely, so this is
my eighth year of teaching
and I've been really lucky
to have very different
teaching experiences.
I have taught in two different
states, in five districts.
I've taught in rural,
suburban, urban settings
and I've taught middle
school and elementary.
Currently, I teach third grade.
- Very cool, and how
long have you been using
Khan Academy for and what
do you typically use it for
in your classroom?
- So I've used it for a
little over two years.
And I use it for a lot.
So I got started mainly using it for math
and that's how I do my
math homework actually
is through Khan Academy.
But over time as I've gotten
more comfortable with it,
I use so much on it now.
I use grammar, I use the ELA beta
that just came out recently,
I use the computer programming
and I also use history.
- Very cool, okay,
it sounds like you're a
Khan Academy super user.
So that's perfect.
That's what we need.
And so for those who wanna
aspire for super user status
that are just getting
started today, especially
in this difficult environment
we find ourselves in,
any beginner tips for just
getting started with Khan Academy
especially as it pertains to ELA?
- You know, I think that
some of the easiest ways
to get started...
Well, if you're elementary,
I really recommend
adding multiple courses to your classroom,
so adding math, grammar and the beta ELA
and then just explore
what those have to offer.
I think the ELA beta is really
awesome to be able to use
more complete units of study
and then the grammar is nice
for those little check-ins to
reinforce skills you've taught
in the classroom.
- Very cool, let's actually
just pull up some of that
so folks can see it on their screen.
So basically we just added a new class.
And out of curiosity, 'cause
I know this always comes up,
how do you get your students enrolled?
I know it's especially a challenge
with elementary students.
- Yeah, so if you're
middle or high school,
I say don't enroll them yourself.
Share it, push it out
via Google Classroom.
It's really easy on Khan
Academy to do it that way.
But if you're elementary,
especially right now,
I would just go ahead
and create your student's
accounts for them.
I know that so many
parents are overwhelmed.
And so that's just one
thing that you can do.
All you have to do is
type in the student's name
and then a username and
password will be created,
then you can just email it out to families
and it's really easy.
Just download the CSV for sure.
Some people skip that, which
is really interesting to me.
Don't skip it, download it
so that you would have that
on your computer.
I mean, you can access it other ways,
but that's gonna be the easiest.
- Great, and so once someone
has created their class
and they've applied all
those different courses
that you were talking about,
how would you even get started?
How would you get a student
using ELA on Khan Academy
for the first time?
- So what you're gonna wanna
do is first you're gonna wanna
assign something so that
when the students get
into Khan Academy there is
something for them to do.
And so I teach third grade.
So I would go into the third grade beta
and then just click on a unit.
So right now, I've been doing a lot
of actually the vocabulary
because we've done so much
of that work in the classroom,
I think it's nice during
this time to first start off
with something you have already
covered with them in person.
'Cause if this is new to them,
they're gonna feel more comfortable if,
oh, okay, I know what context clues are,
okay, and then they can do an assignment
that feels a little bit more familiar,
even if it's a new website.
So that's what I started with.
We've been doing so much context clues,
so I assigned them something on there,
even though my students
are comfortable with it.
- And here's an example
of what some of those questions look like.
Now, imagine that someone is
going to start Khan Academy
for the first time not
having that prior experience
in the classroom with it.
Would you recommend rolling this out
over a Zoom conversation
or a Google Meeting,
or how would you even
give students a sense
of what they're supposed to be doing
and what an assignment looks like?
- Yeah, so I would definitely
do some sort of live meeting
and get them excited about it.
Explain why you're gonna be using it.
Maybe you want to share.
If you're not familiar with Khan Academy,
they get mastery points and
they get to create avatars
for themselves and things like that.
And so if you're working
with younger kids like I am,
or even some of the older kids,
they get excited about that.
So walking them through
it, through a share screen
so that they can see what it looks like.
The first time I did Khan Academy,
or the first time I do
Khan Academy with my class
at the beginning of the year,
we always do an assignment together.
And so you can do that
in your live Hangout.
You could have each of the
kids write down the answer
they think is the correct
one and hold it up.
And then they were doing it together
and they're getting a
tutorial of how to use it.
- Very cool, and so when you're
ready to go to prime time
and say, okay, I wanna make this part
of my regular classroom fabric
such as our classrooms exist today,
how would you?
How would you make it easy
and regular for your students?
- So I think that depends on
what your schedule looks like.
Right now I know that for some teachers,
they are putting an announcement
every day on Seesaw.
Well, you can put a link into Seesaw.
Some people are doing assignments
through Google Classrooms.
Some people are doing a
live check-in every day.
So for me, I'm doing
mostly live check-ins.
And so at the end of my time,
I remind them now is the time
that you're gonna get onto Khan Academy.
I want you to do the assignment
that's named such-and-such.
And so just building it in that
way would be what I suggest.
- Very cool and I'll just
mention that every piece
of content on Khan
Academy has a unique URL.
So if you ever just need
to paste a link to a video
or to a specific
exercise, you can do that.
Or into a Seesaw or a
learning management system,
in addition to the assignment
process that works like this.
As far as the reporting goes,
I know we're in a very
different environment right now,
but how much are you
looking at those reports,
are you translating it into
grades, does it matter?
- So I am not doing grades.
That's not an expectation
at the elementary level.
However, I am still using those reports.
So one of the things
that I see as fantastic
about Khan Academy is
there are great videos
that are tutorials for
the students to use.
So I don't have to spend
my time doing that.
There's great lessons.
I don't have to spend my time doing that.
Instead, I can use my time
looking at those reports.
And so just a quick story
of what happened today.
I assigned two math
assignments and I was looking
at the scores from students.
One of my top math kiddos scored poorly.
And so then I was able to
look at a different report
which shows student activity.
So then it shows me how long
students have spent, not just
navigating the pages, but
actually on the assignments.
I mean, he had spend six
minutes on two assignments,
which is just not enough time
for the type of assignments
that I had uploaded.
And so because I had this extra
time, I was able to check in
with that family and I just said,
hey, how did the assignments go?
Oh, it turns out their
wi-fi was in and out
and he was really stressed about that
and tried to get both assignments in
before the wi-fi went out again.
And so I wouldn't have known that
if I didn't have those
reports to look back on.
I could've just been like,
oh, this was a tough skill
for him and moved on.
But instead, I got to
build that relationship
and talk to him about it's totally fine.
If you have to wait until later
to get it done, that's fine.
There's no stress to get
this done right away.
- Very cool,
so I love how you closed
the feedback loop there.
I feel like as teachers
in our normal classrooms,
we're constantly having that
feedback loop all day every day
where a student does some work,
we're giving them a response,
they're getting that needed
feedback versus it's so hard
in this remote learning environment,
but you're still closing
that loop using Khan Academy
to generate the data, super cool.
So the questions are starting to pour in.
If you're good Madelyn, I'd
love to bring up a question
from Don and Herb and Kelly,
which is what is an ELA beta?
What does that even mean?
How should we be thinking about that?
- So basically Khan Academy,
and you can talk to this
probably much better,
but they are adding English
language arts as part
of their lessons and they're
just in beta right now.
So that means that they're
testing them out, they're seeing
what's working well, what's
not, getting feedback
from people so that they can improve them.
- Absolutely.
- But so right now,
there's multiple topics
that you can choose from.
So there's reading passages.
There's non-fiction and fiction
and then there's also just specific skills
like I talked about with the vocabulary
like using glossaries and
dictionaries and things like that.
So I'm super excited about it.
- Cool, and I just shared
the link with everyone.
If you wanna use it and give
us feedback, please just use
that link and let us know
'cause our content developers
are really eager for
that kind of information,
speaking of feedback loops.
Let's see here.
Okay, so Ramona says I'm a fifth grade ELA
and social studies
teacher looking for ways
to integrate Khan Academy
into my remote learning instruction.
I already have my students
working through Google Classroom.
Are there any special tips you would offer
for Google Classroom users
given that you use it?
- Awesome, so I use Google
Classroom, too, and there's a lot
of compatibility between Khan
Academy and Google Classroom,
which is fantastic.
And you can actually in
your Khan Academy account
even sync your Google Classroom
to your Khan Academy class.
And yeah, perfect.
- And then explain a little bit more
about what does syncing look like?
What does that actually do for the teacher
or for the students?
- So then it just makes it...
I wish that I could...
- I don't think you have
to share your screen
'cause I know you've got
your students' personal
information on there.
We've got our fabricated data here.
- Yeah, so then it just
shares the information.
- Yeah, I thought the
easiest way to explain it is
if you've already done the
hard work of getting students
onto Google Classroom and
everyone's all set up there,
if you have to add a student
or change a student in Google classroom,
those changes are automatically populated
in your Khan Academy class.
So that way you don't have to double work
because it's all being fed over.
- And I know there's been a lot of concern
about too much information
going out to families.
And so this is a way that
you can cut down on that.
And there's less for
the students to click.
- Oh, I got a really juicy
question for you from Kathleen.
I love this question.
I know it's very tempting
in the middle of this crisis
to be totally focused on
just getting through the day.
I am certainly that way most days.
But if we're already
thinking about next year
and setting our students up for success,
if a student starts
Khan Academy this year,
will their data go with them
to their next year's teacher
so they can benefit from understanding
what they've done so far?
- Oh, that's an awesome question.
Well, it depends on hopefully
your students are signing up
with their school email
or just using the same login,
then my understanding is that it should.
I haven't followed the
same group of students
and I was teaching at an older grade,
but from what my students
have told me, it follows them.
Do you have more on that?
- Absolutely, no, you nailed it.
So basically as long as they're logging in
with their school account
and that school account stays the same,
they'll carry all that
good information with them
and future teachers can benefit.
Lots of questions from high
school educators like Nancy
and Jennifer saying, hey,
I love all this stuff
for third through eighth grade ELA,
what about us high school teachers?
Would you recommend that the
vocabulary and grammar lessons
are relevant for those students as well?
- I think it really
depends on those students.
I mean, you are the
experts on your students.
You're gonna know that the best.
I've used the grammar with middle school
and I'm sure high school
teachers, you would agree
that there are some holes in grammar.
And so I would certainly
use it for high school.
And what you might just wanna
change what that looks like
and you might want to...
There's unit tests for each thing.
So if we go to sentence and
clauses or if we go to nouns,
then there's gonna be a unit test.
So it might just look different
where you would find
that at the beginning.
And see how they do on
that and then figure out
what individual skills you wanna go over,
instead of assigning
every single assignment.
- I love that and actually
you echoed exactly
what Tim Vandenberg, your
fellow ambassador had shared
a couple weeks ago, which is
even for his sixth graders,
he has them go back and actually
master each of these things
because if they didn't learn
about nouns in the first grade,
if they didn't learn about
adverbs in third grade,
he can actually fill in those gaps
and make sure they're
ready for sixth grade work
or even ninth grade work.
- Yep.
Okay, let's see here.
Okay, here's an important question.
I think this really speaks probably
to the elementary population
that you're most familiar with.
Marta wants to know if
I've already created
the students' usernames and
passwords via the process
that you just outlined, what should I send
to the parents and the
students themselves?
Should I just send them
that information directly
or is there any preferred way
to go about that communication?
- So I've never had to do
it with distance learning,
so that's a great question.
What I would do is...
Again, each school looks
different right now.
We're having to send out
a weekly email to parents
and so you could input it within that.
And then so that's
probably what I would do
is just screenshot the user,
each individual username
and you could do that.
Oh, perfect.
- Yeah, I was gonna add, I
think you're absolutely right.
Totally the best way to do
it or whatever's natural
for your communication
style, if you're using Seesaw
or screen capture tools.
Khan Academy does have a
formal letter to parents
where you can list it that's in a bunch
of different languages, which
I'll share in the chat here.
And you can always take advantage of these
if you just need some
language to get started with.
But I think that your point
is totally valid, Madelyn.
Okay, hopefully that
gets you started, Marta.
I know it's a tough thing to
do midstream, especially given
that the stream we're wading
in right now is very deep.
Ooh, here's a really interesting question.
This is gonna challenge you a little bit.
But Shelly who's actually
working with students
that are focused on GED wants
to know if there are parts
of Khan Academy that are
actually even appropriate
for self-directed learning.
So less about assignment,
assignment, assignment,
more about I'm empowered to go
forth and learn as a student.
- Yeah, actually I think
that something that
the more comfortable
you can get any student
with Khan Academy, the more
that will naturally happen,
even for an older learner, it's
gonna happen very naturally.
It can definitely be self-paced.
Some of my third graders, in
the time that they were waiting
for me to get up and running
with online education,
assigned themselves computer
programming and biology
and started going through those lessons.
And so absolutely, this would be great
for self-paced instruction.
- Very cool and just to
make that really lucid,
any single user of Khan Academy
whether you're a teacher
or a student can always
click this courses button
in the upper left-hand corner
and really can start digging in
on whatever they're curious about.
So if you do have adult
learners, older learners
who are ready to just dominate
grammar or whatever it is
that they need to learn,
they can get started
even without assignments.
Always available to you.
Okay, great question, Shelly.
Great response, Madelyn.
Ooh, here's a tough one.
So Krista says when setting this up
for an autistic eighth grade
girl, what do you think
is the best approach and
if the student had ADHD,
would you think about it
differently in terms of engagement?
So basically just thinking
about all your different kinds
of learners, I need advice for making sure
that they're all served really well
using a tool like Khan Academy.
- So again it's gonna depend
on your individual student
and what works best for them.
So for one of my students who has autism,
she actually really prefers
the videos on Khan Academy
to anything else.
The use of color is really
calming to her and she loves it.
And so when I posted a video
of my online instruction,
her mom emailed me and said,
is there actually a Khan Academy version?
So for her, it worked really
well and so much better.
For another one of my students,
this student has autism,
he did not like the Khan Academy videos,
but he loved the activity and
doing the assignment on there.
He just prefers getting
the instruction from me.
So there's gonna be give and take
and just I guess having
that conversation with them
about what's working
with us and what's not
and teachers were really flexible.
So just keeping that
flexibility with this as well.
- Very cool, great feedback.
Actually very similar,
Caesar wants to know
do you have any students who
are English language learners
and if so, how do you address that
given that so much of this is text based?
- So I do have some students
that are English language learners.
So you can actually turn on captions.
And so I will do that with the videos
because sometimes they'll miss something
or they will think that two words is one
and so it just helps with clarity.
So far, it has not been a huge issue
for my students to navigate it.
But there have been times
where with some of the ELA,
I've been moving down
to some second grade,
not because they aren't
able to do the academics,
but I can't put the same supports in
with this distance learning.
Or at least I haven't
figured out a perfect way
to do that yet.
And so there are sometimes
where I might use just a
little bit simpler level
so that they can access it easier.
- Great advice, Madelyn.
That leads to a bigger question.
Can you speak to the
idea of differentiation
on Khan Academy a bit more broadly?
When we did our initial
demo, we were mostly talking
about lock step, everyone
gets the same assignment.
If you wanted to serve each
student where they are,
how would you go about doing that?
- There's so many
different ways to do that.
And it might even
actually be easier for you
because you've been working
with your students in person
up to this point, so you
probably have a pretty good idea
of where they're at, so
you can assign from there.
If you don't, if it's a new concept,
then you can see how they're
doing on the assignments
and then you can scale back.
There's actually if you're doing math,
there's very clear cut
if you need remediation
in third grade, click here,
if you need supports for this, click here.
And then with ELA, it's not
there yet because it's in beta,
but you can just yourself look
through the different levels
and you can make it more challenging
for your students that need that.
Assign them a fourth
grade or a fifth grade
or go the other way.
- Cool, and just to operationalize that,
anywhere you can make
assignments on the site,
whether it's on the lesson itself
or in the teacher classroom,
you always have the chance
to do all students or
just some of the students.
So you can really make sure
that every student is
getting what they need,
not just whatever the class is getting.
Speaking of getting what you need,
Nathan, a parent, actually asks
a really important question,
which is I'm a parent of a
second grader and I'm trying
to make sure that my
daughter has what she needs
to get ready for third grade,
but I don't wanna just skip
to third grade and start
her on that ELA beta.
Do you recommend anything to get started
at that second grade level?
- Well, so I would suggest doing some
of the grammar lessons.
That would be really good.
There's some pretty basic
things in there like nouns,
singular nouns, things like that.
So I would do that I would think.
And then I don't think there's any harm
with doing what beta is
available for second grade
and fill in the time with that for now.
- Yeah, have you ever used Khan Kids
with your students at all, Madelyn?
- Well, not with my students,
but I have two little ones
and with my three-year-old,
he uses Khan Academy.
He's not going to preschool anymore
which was pretty devastating for him
and so he uses Khan Academy
Kids and he loves it.
And he was really excited
because that is continuing
to develop and so recently
there was assignments
for first grade that came up
and he was so excited about new videos.
So it's a great tool.
It's an app that it'll
go through short lessons
and you can either select
the lessons yourself
or you can just press play
and it will lead you through lessons.
- Absolutely, as all three,
all along the bottom,
these app stores as you
can see on the screen.
And in some ways, it's easier
to get started with especially
in this remote learning
environment, 'cause like you said,
Madelyn, you just start
it and it just goes
and you don't have to worry
about all these assignments
and everything else.
So could be a nice way
for the early elementary
educators out there
to get their students started.
- And you can still get reports.
- Right, Sara from Guilford
County, North Carolina asks
and this is a very important question,
can you actually preview
the lesson and videos
before you assign them
or are you basically
just shooting in the dark
and hoping for the best?
- No, you can absolutely preview anything.
I typically do the assignment myself.
Now, there's sometimes with
some of the assignments,
there's lots of different
possible questions
that could be asked
and I'll just run through one possibility,
but just so I have a good idea
of what I'm actually
asking students to do.
So yes, you can preview
everything, which is really nice.
You can preview because the students
when they're doing the assignment
can have access to hints.
And so I like to see what
those are going to look like
for the students.
- Very cool, and a little pro
tip just to go along with that
is if you're ever curious
what your students are
experiencing, I'm sure you are,
add yourself as a student
to your own classroom.
And that way, you
actually have the ability
to see every email, every
notification, everything
that your students are about to get.
And all you have to do is come in here
to your classroom dashboard,
go to the class code
in the upper right-hand corner
and then under your name,
go to learner home.
And from there, you can actually
add yourself as a student
and see everything that the
student sees through their eyes.
Have you ever done that, Madelyn?
Has that ever--
- Mm-hmm.
Okay, cool, cool.
- And then also I just add
courses that I'm interested in.
So I think I have astronomy
in there right now.
And so I show the kids this is
something I'm excited about,
I'm gonna be learning.
And so then they feel like
you're using this, too.
You're a learner, too and it
builds that connection, too.
- I love that.
Any tips, speaking of that,
about just growth mindset,
especially this moment when
we feel like so deflated
and we're like I don't even
wanna think about tomorrow.
How do you keep your students
feeling really strong
and persistent right now?
- That's a good question.
Just keeping things light.
At the beginning of each academic year,
I do gross mindset lessons
with them through Khan Academy,
a course that they have
available that's nice
to help kids get into that mindset.
But I think just continuing
the connection with your kids
is so important in whatever way you can.
- Very cool, and then two
final questions for you.
Number one, where do you
typically go to get support
if you run into challenges
with Khan Academy
or just wanna learn from other educators?
- So there are some Facebook groups
for Khan Academy educators
and that's really nice
because you get feedback really quickly.
You can just type in your question,
hey, who's run into this?
Or hey, I'm running into this issue,
how have you motivated students?
And you get responses really quickly.
So I highly recommend joining that.
It is a private group, so
just have to ask for access.
- Very cool, and then lastly,
as we face the tough month ahead of us
and maybe even a little
more, any words of wisdom
that you wanna share with
ELA educators out there
just as far as how to
stay strong in this moment
and how to serve their
students the best way possible?
- I think take a deep
breath and less is more.
You're doing the best that
you can for your students
just by being there and by trying
and it's just gonna be
a steep learning curve.
So try to have as much
fun with it as you can.
- Cool, I think those are
great words to end on.
So Madelyn, thank you so
much for being with us today.
You learn from your own
children, your own students
to serve other educators.
And thank you all for joining
us and we wish you well
on your journey in the
next couple months ahead.
- Absolutely, thank you
so much for having me.
- Have a great day, all.